stellen sie sich vor sie müssten alles
vorbereitet für den fall dass sie von
einem tag auf den anderen nicht mehr da
sind dass ihr kleines kind vielleicht
alleine und ratlos auf der straße steht
inmitten von zerstörungen gleichen und
sie können ihrem kind nicht mehr helfen
weil ihr kind auch neben ihrer leiche
stehen könnte für uns alle es ist ein
schreckliches kaum zu ertragende
szenario für mütter und väter in der
ukraine ist das wirklichkeit und so
bereiten sie sich auf diesen fall vor
das ist wie sie ist erst zwei jahre alt
und mit kugelschreiber hat ihre mama
alexandra marco wie name und
geburtsdatum oft rücken beschrieben und
die telefonnummern von mama papa wieder
steht da in ihrem kinderzimmer in kiew
mit ihrer windel für ihr mal tisch und
den krieg den trägt sie auf ihrem
kleinen rücken mit zittrigen händen hat
wir us mutter alexandra ihrem kind das
auf den rücken geschrieben dieses bild
von wir das geht gerade um die welt und
ich spreche jetzt exklusiv mit der us
mutter ich begrüße ganz herzlich
alexandra im akw guten abend ihren
alexandra
als sie beschlossen haben dass wir auf
den rücken zu schreiben was ist da
gerade in kiew passiert und vor allem
was ging ihnen als mutter durch das herz
dieses foto habe ich am 24 februar
gemacht
broken record run sie wird wir sind
aufgewacht und haben wir regieren durch
schläge gehört
die haben unsere sachen schnell gepackt
meine skill gebote bei special
wir wussten nicht was vorsteht
meine hände haben gezittert
ich habe geweint
das ist mein größter stolz
und ich habe mir gedacht wenn russen
haben wenn mir etwas zustoßen würde
nicht wissen
wir sehen ist
ich habe auf ihren reisen
wer sie ist und
auch unsere telefonnummer dass die leute
uns dass die leute über uns dann
erfahren
ich habe auf unsere adresse geschrieben
haben wir dann key verlassen richtung
fest
ich das geschrieben
hände so gezittert wie noch nie im leben
[Musik]
wir konnten uns nicht wir konnten nicht
glauben dass es in unserer realität
passiert
was haben sie vera gesagt wie erklärt
man einem kind sie ist erst zwei jahre
alt was da passiert
bin ich krank war dass sie noch so klein
ist dass sie noch nicht alles versteht
ihren
spielen
und sie hat immer gesagt zu mir abc mama
schreibst du abc
sie dachte ihr buch starten auf dem
rücken
das ist alexandra für eltern die absolut
schlimmste vorstellung man liebt ja als
eltern sein kind mehr als man selbst und
dass man sich selbst liebt und die
vorstellung für das kind nicht da sein
zu können weil plötzlich ein krieg über
einen kommt dass man sein kind nicht
beschützen kann sie haben das glück hat
sie konnten hier verlassen aber dennoch
sind sie ja mit dieser angst so brutal
konfrontiert gewesen wie sind sie mit
dieser angst umgegangen
ich hatte so viel
sicherheit gekommen
ich denke ich bin ja ich war nicht die
einzige die so was gemacht haben
ich habe
von vielen eltern erfahren die das
gleiche gemacht haben
der ukrainische mütter haben das gleiche
dann wie ich
dieses foto gesehen auf ihrem instagram
account in dieses foto geht um die welt
und ganz viele eltern schreiben auch
darunter dass sie in in schneeanzüge die
adresse verstecken dass sie den kindern
auf die hand schreiben auf den rücken
schreiben immer aus der sorge man könnte
das kind auf der flucht verlieren oder
man könnte das kind im krieg verlieren
oder man könnte selbst opfer dieses
krieges werden diese situation dort
dieses foto das berührt so sehr sie
steht da in ihrer kleinen winde das war
der tag des kriegsbeginns dort im
februar können sie uns diesen morgen es
scheint so als sei ihre tochter gerade
erst aufgestanden als würde sie
eigentlich spielen wollen und dennoch
hat sich dieser alltag dann ganz
plötzlich für sie von einem tag auf den
anderen verändert
in der zeit habe ich sagen sind ein paar
und
konnte noch nicht begreifen dass wir
[Musik]
wie in einer anderen realität ich habe
ja noch mein mann gefragt
fliegen oder fahren wir nicht
alles okay
das
gab die raketen wurden lauter und lauter
und dank entscheidend getroffen wir
müssen die stadt verlassen
sowie auf eine insel im fluss newa und
da haben wir sogar keinen schutz keller
wir hätten uns auch nicht verstecken
kann
da auf der insel ganz klar das klavier
muss und wir mussten fliehen
ist nicht alles verstanden sind sie hat
weiter gespielt sie hat gemalt
sie hat sich um gekleidet
[Musik]
und dann auch mit mir oder mit dem
fahrrad mit dem vater gespielt war sehr
gut drauf
die ehre tochter jetzt nach zu hause
fragt ihre tochter eines zurückgeht nach
hause fragt ihre tochter was krieg
bedeutet das nämlich sehr dass
das team
nach den verwandten die sie schon lange
nicht gesehen hat
die erste woche jetzt ständig wiederholt
nach hause nach hause
das ist mein hobby es ist meine mama sie
hat dann auch nach der oma gefragt bis
jetzt haben wir uns mit oma nicht
getroffen
meine mutter nicht
anrufen weil wir ständig nach oma
gefragt hat ich wollte ihr nicht mehr
noch nicht mehr wehtun
ich habe sehr viel geweint
erklären musste dass er nach hause gehen
können
ich wusste auch nicht ob unser zuhause
noch existiert
gut dass sie und dass ihre kleine
tochter dass sie jetzt in sicherheit
sind und vielen dank dass sie mit uns
über diese schmerzhaften erlebnisse hier
gesprochen haben